des habitants armés tous volontaires ils
font désormais partie de la police
communautaire de thello lohan une ville
mexicaine de plus de 50000 habitants
dans l'état du guerrero depuis le 13
avril et pour éviter la propagation du
coc u19 ils ont décidé de fermer les
frontières terrestres aux étrangers et
mini à nos 25 ans était étudiant avant
de rentrer au sein de la police
communautaire
il expose la situation va parler - une
pandémie arrive ça va être très
difficile
en réalité je pense que nous ne sommes
pas suffisamment équipés nous n'avons
pas les équipements nécessaires pour
prendre en charge les malades de plus
nous allons subir les conséquences
économiques car nous n'avons plus de
travail
la population ici vit au jour le jour
maman sera levé le maire de la ville
soutient ses actions et de nombreuses
mesures sont prises pour éviter la
propagation du virus
la place centrale est local o et
condamné la quarantaine et le couvre-feu
imposé ce pendant l'occupation des
entrées de la ville et la détention
d'armes par des citoyens pose la
question de la légalité de ce dispositif
effectivement mais les routes ne sont
pas fermées elles sont soumises à un
contrôle
on fait attention à qui entrent et par
quels moyens
elles ne sont pas fermées il vient
contrôler insistant mais ce n'est pas
fermée
la mairie de thello l'oapam soutient ces
actions qui nous protège aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de kovy d'ici à tello à panne
et nous voulons que ça continue comme ça
j'espère que la situation ne deviendra
pas aussi compliquée que celle que nous
pouvons voir en europe ou aux états unis
le docteur armando mojica approuve lui
aussi les précautions mises en oeuvre
pour éviter la propagation du coït 19
dans la ville et alerte sur la situation
sanitaire de la région
les hôpitaux de guerrero et
particulièrement celui de la ville
digoit la compte très peu d'appareils
respiratoires
nous avons calculé qu'il y a plus ou
moins quatre appareils pour deux cent
mille habitants
au delà de six huit et 10 patients
hospitalisés
cela devient difficile d'assurer le
service dans des conditions égalitaire
la propagation du virus annoncerait une
crise sanitaire dramatique dans cette
région du mexique déjà frappé par une
insécurité chronique